[Music]
out into the world once more how many
people had forgotten this mask
anytime I'm given a choice between
stealth and action
I go stealth I love to hold your breath
tension of hoping that one guard over
there didn't see me and the hard-earned
triumph of executing a perfectly timed
plan designer two delivers both arming
players with stealth essentials like
hiding bodies peering through keyholes
and silent takedowns but it's also an
incredible engine for gleeful chaos one
so engrossing and amusing that I
actually accidentally beat the entire
campaign raining hilarious elaborate
death on my enemies I kick people
through skylights blasted them off
seaside cliffs lured them into
bottlenecks and watched as my carefully
placed Rapinoe grenade shredded them up
at one point I got murdered badly so I
reloaded a quick save shot a guard with
an incendiary bolt and blew up another
four with one grenade when they ran to
help
sadistic yes but also incredibly
satisfying from a gameplay standpoint
moments like that happened constantly in
Dishonored - because it's as much a toy
box as it is a game it's meant to be
experimented with it rewards and even
demands creativity this was true of the
first game and it's true here as well
mainly because the sequel simply takes
the original formula and built on it
you'll find more ways to engage enemies
without killing them like non-lethal
drop attacks and parries that start
opponents momentarily allowing you to
grab them and choke them out there are
new weapons and gadgets including
crossbow bolts that blind enemies or
send them sprinting in a chemical
induced madness weapons can be upgraded
in new ways so your starter pistol can
eventually be modded into a semi-auto
hand cannon with explosive ricocheting
rounds and most importantly there's an
entirely new protagonist with their own
set of powers
you can still play his classic hero
Corvo and enjoy all his original
supernatural abilities like pausing time
and possessing rodents but emperor's
emily kaldwin offers some exciting new
choices kiss
much like the gadgets and weaponry the
diverse and inventive mechanics inherent
in these powers turn the gameplay into a
joyful cycle of experimentation and
reward as nearly all can be used in a
variety of ways ranging from
straightforward to truly unconventional
part of what makes the experimentation
so fun is the fact that your enemies are
genuinely threatening which makes
cleverly dispatching them feel that much
more empowering they parry dodge flank
kick you away even throw rocks at you to
keep you off balance and they never
relent rather than telegraphing their
attacks or waiting patiently for you to
strike they just come at you which both
gets your adrenaline pumping and make
sure one-hit-kill counter-attacks feel
earned and if you're a stealth player
they're smart and aware enough to
present a real challenge frequently
breaking from the preset pattern
behavior observable in many other
stealth games this makes for a demanding
experience overall but weirdly the
campaign doesn't really grow more
challenging as you progress you'd think
you'd face new more intricate scenarios
or larger numbers of tougher enemies but
that's not really the case unexpected
new enemy types do emerge but feel
underutilized as they're limited to
certain levels in areas by the end I
actually felt overpowered because the
game never demanded more of me
dishonored does such a stellar job of
consistently adding new gameplay
elements it's a shame that it never
culminated in a grand all-encompassing
challenge the story also doesn't evolve
much over the course of the campaign the
original game opened with a bloody power
grab that since you want to quest for
vengeance the plot here is essentially
identical just with more cryptic occult
gibberish the plotline is fine but the
delivery proves lackluster contrary to
the gameplay the storytelling holds your
hand bombarding you with heavy-handed
exposition your character constantly
states the obvious in game then narrates
their exact thoughts and feelings over
motion comics between missions
everything I know has been turned on its
head
but I'm dealing with it the best I can
still dishonored world is undeniably
intriguing thanks mainly to the vaguely
steampunk aesthetic and the tangible
history hidden in every detail the
characters you encounter are by and
large interesting and well developed and
the expansive areas you visit feel alive
bursting with unique details there's
also plenty of side content to uncover
in the hub areas from unearthing
backstory to finding the one ultra
clever way to break into a fortified
black-market shop and of course you'll
constantly be hunting for hidden runes
some are obvious some are clever some
are just plain frustrating but you need
them to unlock new powers so get hunting
most impressively individual missions
frequently distinguish themselves by
offering a unique gameplay hook there's
a mission late in the game that involves
time manipulation and might be one of
the most unforgettable standalone
missions in a game ever it is a
masterpiece unto itself
there's also the intricate mind-bending
clockwork mansion which turns the entire
level into a giant Rubik's Cube and just
like before you can find elaborate story
driven ways to eliminate every major
target without actually killing them
dishonour to might lack challenge in its
later levels but the basic tools are a
joy to play with regardless and with two
characters and two basic play styles to
choose from both of which noticeably
impact the story and the world as you go
there's a lot of longevity to be rung
out of the campaign in fact I'm about to
start a new playthrough with no powers
on the highest difficulty setting wish
me luck
let's go